En prépa
et aux concours,
on dit souvent
que la dissertation est
« une épreuve
DE MÉTHODE ».
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire que c’est
LA MÉTHODE
— pas les connaissances —
c’est LA MÉTHODE
qui permet de réussir
une épreuve de dissertation
en prépa et aux concours.
D’accord,
mais c’est quoi
« LA MÉTHODE ».
La méthode,
c’est étymologiquement
LE CHEMIN.
Plus précisément,
c’est UNE SUITE D'OPÉRATIONS
à accomplir
pour arriver à un résultat
EN ÉVITANT
des errements.
Si vous êtes en prépa,
si vous préparez un concours,
ce n’est pas en apprenant votre cours
que vous allez réussir vos dissertations
— c’est en prenant
LE BON CHEMIN.
Pourquoi ma méthode
est-elle SPÉCIALE ?
Parce que je ne l’ai pas apprise
d’un professeur,
ni trouvée dans un manuel.
C’est MOI-MÊME
qui l’ai élaborée
PAR LA PRATIQUE.
J’ai traité DES CENTAINES
de sujets,
fait DES CENTAINES
de plans détaillés,
rédigé DES CENTAINES
de dissertations,
donné DES MILLIERS
d’heures de cours
à des étudiants
qui préparaient des concours
— j’ai fait tout ça
depuis une dizaine d’années,
et j’ai élaboré MA PROPRE
méthode de dissertation
au fur
et à mesure.
J’ai pu tester
beaucoup de choses :
j’ai retiré
ce qui ne marche pas ;
j’ai bien sûr conservé
ce qui marche ;
et j’ai ajouté
de nouvelles techniques
grâce auxquelles
il est BIEN PLUS FACILE
de faire une dissertation.
Alors,
je ne vais pas vous présenter
ma méthode DANS LE DÉTAIL
— ça prendrait BEAUCOUP TROP
de temps.
Donc dans cette vidéo,
je vais simplement vous expliquer
LES SEPT
grandes étapes
que je suis
À CHAQUE FOIS
que je fais une dissertation.
Si vous voulez entrer
dans le détail ;
si vous voulez des consignes précises,
des techniques
et des exemples,
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Comme c’est un cours par e-mail,
vous pourrez le découvrir après la vidéo,
ou dans les prochains jours.
Là maintenant tout de suite,
regardez attentivement cette vidéo
JUSQU’AU BOUT
et vous serez bien plus à l’aise
DÈS
votre prochaine épreuve de dissertation.
Est-ce que vous savez
QUOI FAIRE
lorsque vous découvrez le sujet ?
Beaucoup d’élèves se mettent à réfléchir
sans savoir À QUOI
ils doivent réfléchir.
Mais il y a pire :
des élèves notent frénétiquement
sur leurs feuilles de brouillon
TOUT ce dont ils se souviennent
de leur cours.
Vous pensez VRAIMENT
que c’est ça,
« traiter le sujet » ?
Bien sûr que non.
Quelle est la bonne solution ?
Vous devez d’abord réfléchir
STRATÉGIQUEMENT
au sujet.
C’est pour ça que j’appelle
cette toute première étape
la RÉFLEXION
STRATÉGIQUE.
Mais en quoi ça consiste
précisément,
la « stratégie » ?
Ça consiste
À ANTICIPER
les éventualités.
Vous devez donc vous poser
LES BONNES QUESTIONS
sur le sujet,
afin UN,
d’en identifier les enjeux,
c’est-à-dire
ce qui est important pour le traiter,
ET DEUX,
de prévoir des pistes de solution
pour faire face aux difficultés
et tirer parti des opportunités.
Moi,
je donne à mes élèves
une liste de questions SIMPLES.
Comme ça,
ils n’ont pas besoin
de se prendre la tête
pour traiter le sujet de leur dissertation
:
dès qu’ils découvent l’énoncé,
ils ont SIMPLEMENT
à répondre à quelques questions.
Cette TOUTE PREMIÈRE
étape est probablement
la PLUS IMPORTANTE,
parce qu’elle vous permettra
d’éviter les pièges,
de disserter plus efficacement,
et de gagner du temps.
Allez,
deuxième étape !
J’imagine que ça vous est déjà arrivé,
le hors-sujet.
Mais comment savoir
si vous êtes DANS
le sujet ?
Comment savoir si vos idées
sont PERTINENTES ?
Comment savoir
SI VOUS N’OUBLIEZ PAS
des idées IMPORTANTES ?
Le problème,
c’est souvent
que vous vous perdez
dans le monde des idées.
Votre sujet de dissertation
porte sur une question INTELLECTUELLE,
donc vous croyez
qu’il est SANS RAPPORT
avec la réalité concrète.
Mais C’EST FAUX !
Les idées
et la matière
sont en constante interaction.
Votre sujet
a des racines
ET des implications
dans le monde réel.
C’est pour cette raison
que vous avez intérêt
à CHERCHER
DES EXEMPLES
pour délimiter le champ du sujet.
Un exemple,
c’est bien plus facile
de savoir s’il est pertinent
— et comme ça,
vous saurez si les idées
liées à chaque exemple
le sont,
elles aussi.
Donc la DEUXIÈME ÉTAPE
de ma méthode de dissertation,
ça consiste
à chercher des exemples
CONCRETS
et PRÉCIS.
« CONCRET »,
ça veut dire
que la chose peut être perçue
par les sens ;
et « PRÉCIS »,
ça veut dire que la chose
ne peut pas être redivisée
en éléments plus petits.
Allez,
on passe à
LA TROISIÈME ÉTAPE
de ma méthode de dissertation !
Je viens de vous expliquer
que vous devez trouver
des exemples CONCRETS
et PRÉCIS.
Et qu’est-ce que j’ai fait
IMMÉDIATEMENT
après vous avoir dit ça ?
J’ai défini les adjectifs
« CONCRET »
et « PRÉCIS »
afin que vous puissiez avoir
LA MEILLEURE
compréhension possible
de ma consigne.
Si vous voulez manipuler
EFFICACEMENT
les idées,
ça doit devenir un réflexe :
DÉFINISSEZ
les mots
dont vous vous servez.
Comme la dissertation
est surtout un exercice de RÉFLEXION,
la définition des termes du sujet
est une étape importante de ma méthode
— c’est LA TROISIÈME.
C’est même une étape CRUCIALE
parce qu’elle conditionne
les prochaines étapes.
Par exemple,
c’est peut-être UNE NUANCE DE DÉFINITION
qui vous aidera
à élaborer votre plan ;
ou bien elle vous permettra peut-être
de trouver le problème intellectuel PRÉCIS
à résoudre dans la dissertation.
Bref,
cette étape de la définition des termes
peut être un investissement
TRÈS RENTABLE,
donc définissez les termes du sujet
avec soin.
Allez,
étape suivante !
D’où est-ce que vous la sortez,
la problématique ?
D’un chapeau,
comme un magicien ?
Ou bien est-ce qu’il faut
être INSPIRÉ,
comme un artiste ?
Est-ce qu’il faut
avoir un coup de chance ?
Vous pensez peut-être
que ça se passe comme ça
— et plein d’élèves
pensent comme vous.
C’est pour ça
que j’ai élaboré une technique
LOGIQUE
et SIMPLE
pour problématiser
un sujet de dissertation.
Il suffit de faire TROIS CHOSES :
d’abord,
vous identifiez CLAIREMENT
le point de départ de votre réflexion ;
ensuite,
vous en déduisez
LE PROBLÈME INTELLECTUEL
à résoudre dans la dissertation ;
et enfin,
vous FORMULEZ
ce problème intellectuel
sous la forme d’une question.
Là,
je vous ai simplement PRÉSENTÉ
les opérations de ma technique,
parce que j’ai déjà publié une vidéo
qui vous explique tout
dans le détail.
Elle s’intitule
« Problématique de dissertation :
comment la trouver logiquement »
— vous la trouverez facilement
sur cette chaîne YouTube.
Je ne vous en dis donc pas plus
sur la problématisation.
On passe
à la cinquième étape !
Après qu’on vous a posé
une question,
c’est le moment…
de répondre !
Une fois que vous avez trouvé
LA QUESTION
— c’est-à-dire
la problématique —
c’est donc le bon moment
de réfléchir à la réponse.
C’est pour ça
que vous devez élaborer
le plan de votre dissertation
MAINTENANT,
et non pas AVANT
— et encore moins
AU DÉBUT
de l’épreuve.
La CINQUIÈME ÉTAPE
de ma méthode de dissertation,
ça consiste donc
à élaborer LE PLAN.
Mais par « plan »,
j’entends seulement
les GRANDES PARTIES
du développement de votre dissertation
— selon votre épreuve
et votre sujet,
il y en aura deux,
trois,
ou quatre.
Concentrez-vous EXCLUSIVEMENT
sur les GRANDES PARTIES,
parce que si vous cherchez en même temps
les grandes parties,
les sous-parties,
et les références,
ça sera plus compliqué,
et vous risquerez de mélanger
les différents niveaux d’idées
(les idées plus générales
avec les idées plus précises).
Allez,
étape suivante !
Je ne vais pas vous jeter la pierre :
moi aussi,
quand je découvre un sujet,
je pense instantanément
à des références
— je me dis par exemple :
« Ah tiens,
je pourrais parler d’Aristote ».
Non,
pas toi Haristote.
Moi aussi,
je réfléchis automatiquement comme ça,
lorsque je découvre le sujet
— MAIS ce n’est pas pour autant
que je me dis
« il faut À TOUT PRIX
que je parle d’Aristote ! ».
Ce n’est pas pour autant
que je mets à grifouiller
TOUTES LES RÉFÉRENCES
qui me viennent à l’esprit
sur mes feuilles de brouillon.
Non,
vous devez concentrer votre esprit
sur les références
AU BON MOMENT.
Une fois que vous connaissez
les grandes parties
du développement de votre dissertation,
c’est le bon moment !
Cette étape,
c’est ce que j’appelle
« L’ARGUMENTATION ».
Il s’agit de trouver les arguments,
c’est-à-dire les idées PRÉCISES
qui prouvent la pertinence
des idées GÉNÉRALES
que sont les grandes parties
du développement de votre dissertation.
Et c’est là que,
pour convaincre le correcteur
de la CRÉDIBILITÉ
de vos arguments
— c’est là que vous
cherchez des références,
ou plus généralement
des éléments de connaissance.
D’accord ?
Allez,
septième et DERNIÈRE
étape de ma méthode !
Bon,
vous avez compris :
qu’est-ce qu’il reste ?
Eh bien il reste
LA RÉDACTION !
Vous avez
vos définitions des termes du sujet,
votre problématique,
vos grandes parties,
vos arguments
et vos références
— vous avez
TOUS les ingrédients,
donc il est temps de cuisiner !
La septième
et dernière étape de ma méthode,
ça consiste donc à rédiger
— toujours
MÉ-THO-DI-QUE-MENT —
l’introduction,
le développement,
et la conclusion
de votre dissertation.
Si vous voulez des consignes PRÉCISES
pour rédiger les trois parties
de la dissertation,
j’ai publié des vidéos
concernant chacune d’entre elles
— vous les trouverez facilement
sur cette chaîne YouTube.
Je vous rappelle
les SEPT ÉTAPES
de ma méthode de dissertation
pour la prépa
et les concours :
réfléchir STRATÉGIQUEMENT
au sujet,
chercher DES EXEMPLES,
DÉFINIR
les termes du sujet,
PROBLÉMATISER
le sujet,
trouver LES GRANDES PARTIES
du développement
de la dissertation,
trouver LES ARGUMENTS
et LES RÉFÉRENCES,
et enfin,
combiner TOUS CES INGRÉDIENTS
pour rédiger la dissertation finale.
Si vous vous inspirez
de ma méthode,
voire même
si vous suivez exactement
les mêmes étapes,
vous allez vous rendre la tâche
BIEN PLUS FACILE.
Maintenant,
si vous voulez des consignes précises,
des techniques
et des exemples,
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère vraiment
que cette vidéo vous aidera
à être PLUS MÉTHODIQUE
en dissertation.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour réussir vos épreuves de dissertation.